Uh, okay, let's go next to our caller from
the four one seven area code.
Who's calling today from four one seven.
[inaudible].
Hi David.
This is Jared.
Hey Jared.
What's going on?
Um, yeah.
Hi.
So I have a couple of questions.
Um, first of all, uh, last night we actually
saw a little bit more of this, but, um, I
have noticed that Bernie has, uh, not been
talking so much about campaign finance, right.
Um, which he was like huge on in 2016.
Um, and I think that like, sorry, I'm nervous.
I think that like, that's really important.
Um, and it's, and it's like, you know, even
if we elect elected Bernie or Elizabeth Warren,
um, it will be important to solve like the
fundamental problem going forward or which
is elect people who talk like progressive's
but you don't actually believe the things
I say.
Yeah.
Yep.
That's on that.
Listen, here's what I think is going on.
There was a different Bernie this week than
in the first debate and I think people have
been advising him and one of the things that
Bernie is doing is he is number one being
more aggressive, which I think worked well
for him.
And number two, I think he's focusing on what
our voting issues in the Democratic primary,
the views of the Democrats, uh, that have
a shot in the primary on campaign finance
are relatively similar.
I'm not saying that they are the same, so
I don't think it's something on which Bernie
can distinguish himself in a way that will
garner him an advantage.
So I think that it's, I agree that he's not
talking about it as much.
I think it's strategy and it may be the right
strategy.
Okay.
Um, yeah.
And then my other question was actually, uh,
about, um, you did a segment on like where
you took a call where someone was talking
about raising the minimum wage and then like
you brought in ubi and you're saying that
both of those things are bandaids for the
more fundamental problem of, you know, this
vast, uh, income inequality.
Yes.
Um, so if you, so in my mind ubi was sort
of like the thing that wasn't a bandaid.
Um, so what if you do, if you think ubi is
like, you know, just like a bandaid, just
like raising wages is, what do you think is
the fundamental solution if you think there
is one?
It's, it's a much bigger reorganization of
the relationship between corporations, government
and elites and basically everybody else which
exceeds sort of the scope of this call.
Uh, but we may do a deep dive on it sometime
soon, but that's like a major, major topic
of, of that we should dig into in significant
detail.
Um, and to be clear, UBI is one type of bandaid
to call something just a bandaid doesn't mean
don't do it.
Uh, but it's just sort of pointing out that
it's not fixing the underlying issue.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
Cool.
I would really love to see like uh, segments
or you know, shows in the future where you,
where you talking more about what you think,
um, the a more permanent solution.
Um, you know what that would entail.
Um, cause I'd be curious to hear what your,
all right, we will do that.
A Jared, thank you so much for the call.
Great to hear from you.
We will take a quick break if you are holding,
please don't hang up because we will get right
back to the phones momentarily.